[Music]
on this Tuesday night inside a refugee
camp in the West Bank welcome to come we
search the freedom Ground Zero of the
Palestinian resistance and the fight
against Israel dozens of dayc carees in
Alberta begin rolling closures the anger
over $10 a day
daycare long delayed improvements for
Canada's Long-Term Care Homes I don't
feel good about what I see a wakeup call
about what needs to be fixed
now and restoring the pyramids project
of the century or ridiculous
renovation global national with Donna
freezen good evening and thanks for
joining us we begin with breaking news
this afternoon four NHL players were
charged in connection with an alleged
sexual assault in London Ontario 5 years
ago that brings the total number of
people now charged to five McKenzie gray
is following this for us from Ottawa
McKenzie yeah Donna the identities of
the former Canadian world junor hockey
team members said to be involved in an
alleged group sexual assault of a
23-year-old back in 2018 are now public
legal council for four nhlers including
star Philadelphia Flyers Goldie Carter
har Mike McLoud and Cal foot of the New
Jersey Devils and Calgary Flames forward
Dylan dubet have confirmed the former
world junior team members have been
charged with sexual assault by London
Ontario police now card uh Carter Hart's
lawyer tweeted out that he is innocent
and will provide a full response to this
false allegation in the proper form a
court of law foot's lawyer also
maintained that his client is innocent
of the charge and will fight to clear
his name a similar sentiment shared by
separate statements for Council for
McLoud and dubet as well saying they
deny any criminal wrongdoing will defend
themselves in court and will be pleading
not guilty now their former will junor
teammate and former Ottawa Senator Alex
foron surrendered to police and London
Ontario on Sunday his lawyer confirmed
he's been charged in relation with the
alleged group sexual assault but stated
Alex will vigorously defend his
innocence and ask people not to rush to
judgment without hearing all the
evidence now the gloin mail previously
reported five players from the 2018
World Junior Team have been told to
surrender to police in London to face
sexual assault charges all five of these
players took leave of absences from
their professional teams recently with a
Calgary flame saying that dubet left the
club to deal with quote his mental
health now so far Donna London Police
have not comment under the potential
charges but they have said they're
planning to address the case in a press
conference on February 5th all right
McKenzie gray in Ottawa thank you now to
tensions between America and Iran after
a drone attack that killed three
American soldiers at a military base in
Jordan today President Joe Biden said he
has made a decision on how to respond
and was asked if he blames Iran for the
attack I do hold respond then respond to
hold the Sens that they supplying the
weapons to the people
was three US Army Reserve soldiers died
dozens of others were injured in the
overnight attack Iran denies any
involvement but an iran-backed militia
group has claimed responsibility
President Biden would not elaborate on
how he's decided to respond but did
repeat he does not want a wider war in
the Middle East Iran provides support to
a number of armed groups in the Middle
East including Hamas and Islamic Jihad
who violently oppose Israel's right to
exist and overnight in the occupied West
Bank undercover Israeli Commandos
infiltrated a Palestinian hospital and
killed three Palestinian Fighters
security cameras show about 10 people
disguised as Medics and Muslim women
carrying assault rifles Witnesses say
they entered the hospital at dawn and
killed three Palestinian militants in
their beds one of the men was paralyzed
the IDF claims the men had been hiding
in in that hospital and using it as a
base to plan Terror attacks claims Hamas
has previously denied that hospital is
in Janine one of the most volatile
cities in the occupied West Bank since
October 7th at least 370 Palestinians in
the West Bank have been killed by
Israeli forces that's according to local
Health authorities many of them in
Janine the refugee camp there was set up
more than 70 years ago for Palestinian
refugees who were displaced during the
1948 Israel Palestine conflict it's now
home to more than 10,000 people our crew
was granted rare access to some Islamic
Jihad Fighters there a group Israel says
was responsible for an air strike on a
hospital in Gaza that killed about 500
people Islamic Jihad is also holding
some of the Israeli hostages who were
kidnapped on October 7th Danielle hamam
Jin went to Janine to find out what
drives the anger towards
[Music]
Israel at times the Janine refugee camp
seems like it's been hit by an
earthquake for locals signs of
Destruction are more like scars in their
fight against the Israeli
occupation there's not a single building
around here that doesn't have bullet
holes or hasn't been hit by shrapnel
this neighborhood specifically is often
targeted by the Israeli military it's
where most of the militants were born
and where their families still
live
and those homes are destroyed as
punishment for carrying out what Israel
says are Terror
attacks welcome to camp we search the
freedom various armed Palestinian
factions roam the
streets Mahmud Abu talal was once a
fighter
himself now he guides a new
generation teaching young men how to hit
run and disappear when Israeli soldiers
enter the
campan Janine is Ground Zero for the
Palestinian resistance in the West Bank
but Israel sees it as a hot bed of
terrorists with a growing arsenal of
[Applause]
weapons as night falls the fighters
emerge ready to clash with Israeli
forces
[Music]
Abdullah is with Islamic Jihad which is
backed by Iran and whose fighters in
Gaza took part in the October 7th
attacks it's also the dominant force in
Janine his Allegiance is based more on
funding than ideology he tells us
Islamic Jihad is providing most of the
money and
weapons what is your
goal
[Music]
abdah is 25 and like many here a former
prisoner they know their M16 rifles are
no match against Israeli drones and
heavy armor but they refuse to stand by
when Israeli Special Forces raid their
camp
this was the scene hours
earlier since October 7th Israeli
incursions have been more frequent and
more violent this video was seen around
the world two boys 8 and 15 years old
shot dead in broad
daylight we want to live in this region
two states but there is no security and
Beast to Israeli people without any
security and Beast to palan people in
Gaza in in Jerusalem
everywhere those killed are revered as
Martyrs their images hang everywhere as
tributes
Danielle hamam Jin Global News Janine in
the West
Bank the UN senior humanitarian
coordinator for Gaza says there is no
substitute for the humanitarian role the
UN Agency for Palestinian refugees or
unra plays in Gaza the World Health
Organization is also making an appeal
saying a suspension of funding will only
hurt people in Gaza who desperately need
support several key donors including the
US and Canada have suspended funding to
the UN Aid agency after allegations
several staff members in Gaza were
involved in the October 7th attacks on
Israel Canada did announce today it will
send humanitarian Aid to Gaza through
other channels the minister of
International Development says $40
million will go to groups including the
world food program the Red Cross and
UNICEF this is a commitment that we made
that each and every innocent civilian
who has humanitarian needs we will step
up for them and we're stepping up in a
big way the money will help provide food
food water and Emergency Medical Aid in
Gaza an additional $5 million has been
set aside for Canadian non-governmental
organizations unra says it will have to
cease its operations in Gaza by the end
of February if funding is not
restored the federal government is being
urged to indefinitely pause plans to
expand eligibility for medically
assisted dying or maid Canada was
considering allowing made for people
whose so medical condition is mental
illness but it is a complex and
controversial issue and a parliamentary
committee has concluded Canada's doctors
and healthare system are not ready for
it Eric senson explains why and what
lies
ahead since 2016 at this Toronto
hospital and others thousands of
Canadians have ended their IR remediable
physical suffering through maid medical
assistance in dying but not those with
mental illness I think we were ready to
do this Dr Donna Stewart has been
assessing psychiatric patients for
decades and is disappointed that Ottawa
has delayed expanding maid a second time
she says exceedingly few would meet the
criteria for Grievous intolerable
suffering but they deserve to be treated
equitably I think there's a lot of
stigma against mental illness it's
easier to see somebody with a physical
illness um understand their suffering
but I think we have to accept that
people with mental illness suffer just
as much as people with physical illness
cam H the Canadian Center for addiction
and mental health supports the delay we
don't think the system is ready yet even
even though there has been some work
done over the past year Dr TK Raji is
sympathetic to expanding maid but says
it's difficult for example to Define IR
remediable for mental illness we don't
yet have clear guidelines for the
clinicians and the Physicians and the
nurse practitioner are willing to be
involved in made assessments to uh to
determine eligibility but when will
those with mental illness be eligible
for maid the federal conservatives and
several provinces and territories want
the measured delay indefinitely I think
there's a lot of issues with the
government's approach to maid the
federal health Minister says he cannot
expand maid without the provinces buying
in every single Health Minister from
every single Province every single
territory telling me they're not ready
for the most seriously mentally ill
patients the delay prolongs their trauma
I think that it discriminates against
the Mally ill I think it's going to
leave a lot of Mally ills continuing to
suffer the federal health Minister says
new legislation will lay out a revised
timeline but it looks increasingly
possible the liberal government will
punt the controversial issue to beyond
the next election Eric senson Global
News
Toronto you might think the idea of
making daycare more affordable would be
embraced by everyone but some parents in
Alberta were left scrambling today
because dozens of daycares began rolling
closures they're protesting the
province's $10 a day Child Care Program
quality Child
Care daycare providers gathered outside
City Hall in Le Alberta today they're
among several daycares frustrated with
the roll out of the affordable program
in their view it's created an
underfunded and restrictive environment
Heather Yu West looks at whether the
push back in Alberta is a sign of things
to
come Calgary's little world's daycare
was locked up tight Tuesday to the
frustration of parents and their kids
it's more about him and his needs not
being met because the Alberta Government
the federal government and child care
providers cannot find a compromise
dozens of daycares in Calgary Edmonton
and Lethbridge took part in the one-day
protest organized by the Association of
Alberta Child Care entrepreneurs an
advocacy group of small business owners
whose stated mission is to keep private
Child Care a choice for Alberta families
our intent was never to cause disruption
or inconvenience but really to raise
awareness so that our families and our
parents here know what's actually
happening under this agreement and the
future of childcare Alberta was one of
the last provinces to sign on to
ottawa's $10 a day child care plan back
in 2021 we fully expect that all
provinces and territories will execute
on their agreements they'll follow
through on the commitments and I'm sure
Alberta will be no exception to that
Alberta has until 2026 to roll out the
program but the details of that roll out
are causing operator concern the
protesting group is asking for more
Public Funding and fewer restrictions I
actually think that there's you know
some legitimacy in some of the concerns
and we've been hearing these across the
country the funding is too slow it's not
the systems have not yet been developed
which they should have Alberta isn't the
only Province experiencing challenges
reduced fees have seen an increase in
demand leaving Child Care spaces in
short supply that's why over the last
year we launched two space creation
grants one for the um nonprofit side and
another just a summer for for-profit
operators Alberta's shuttered daycares
are scheduled to open again Wednesday
morning though the group warns More
protest closures could be coming Canada
may be on the road towards an affordable
child care system but there are still
bumps along the way Heather urex West
Global News Calgary a major tragedy on a
Mexican Highway that's coming up plus a
huge fire expected to burn for days in
Texas
a judge in the state of Delaware has
voided the 56 billion pay package of
Tesla CEO Elon Musk ruling the company's
board of directors failed to prove the
Compensation Plan was fair the judge
noted the pay package Tesla granted musk
in 2018 was the largest Compensation
Plan in public corporate history making
him the richest person on the planet
musk has not responded but did tweet
never incorporate your company in the
state of Delaware firefighters are
battling a massive fire at a chicken
farm near
Houston two of the huge chicken barns
are engulfed the fire is now contained
but could burn for days it's not clear
how many chickens burned but one
commercial Barn could hold up to 20,000
Birds facing scrutiny over quality
control Boeing has withdrawn our request
for a safety exemption needed to certify
a new aircraft model the company asked
American Regulators to allow it to begin
delivering at 737 Max 7 airliner even
though its deicing technology did not
meet safety standards the issue affects
other models of the 737 Max that are
already flying last year Regulators
including Transport Canada ordered
pilots flying the affected models to
limit the use of the deicing system in
Mexico a collision between a truck and a
passenger bus has killed at least 19
people the crash happened on a Coastal
Highway near Mazatlan both vehicles were
burned down to their Metal Frames the
cause is under investig
still ahead why experts say Canada's
long-term care isn't ready for the next
Crisis the pandemic seems like a distant
memory now but for those whose loved
ones died in Care Homes the memory is
still haunting residents unable to have
any visitors and not enough staff to
care for those who were left isolated
thousands of people died of covid in
long-term care in Canada and since then
the failures have been well documented
but as Mike Dray explains little action
has been taken and experts are again
sounding the
alarm the Royal Society of Canada report
on restoring trust in the aftermath of
covid begins with a dire warning it is
unlikely that long-term care homes are
ready for another major event and that's
certainly not what families with seniors
in the long-term care system want to
hear Brian Banks's Mother Elizabeth now
in her late '90s has been in a Toronto
home for a decade he sees a system
running on the bare minimum I don't feel
optimistic about kind of the the
trajectory um of things at all um as I
said I think my own experience has been
you know relatively good with with my
mother but uh you know I I don't feel
good about what I see overall in the
whole system for sure Long-Term Care
Homes were disproportionately affected
by covid-19 with more outbreaks
infections and deaths while families
were often left left watching from a
distance still the report found that
Canada did have some success in regards
to infection control protective
equipment and the availability of
vaccines but that they concluded stopped
the Hemorrhage the Affliction meaning
the long-term fix has yet to be solved
it is a crime that people are afraid to
go to a nursing home to a long-term care
home to that end three recommendations
made in the report were identified as
priority addressing the needs of the
workforce tying funding to results and
developing an accountability structure
to ensure it all works thank you so much
some of those gaps could be bridged by
the safe Long-Term Care Act but Health
Minister Mark Holland who said it would
be introduced soon didn't sound
convinced today there's deep challenges
I think that you know Co exposed uh the
the weaknesses in our long-term care
system and the underinvestment that
occurred um this is largely an area of
provincial jurisdiction but we put up
our hand and said we all have to work
together the safe long-term carrot could
be a game changer it could but we don't
know if it will be and there's the rub
addressing High staff turnover rates and
quality of care sounds good on
paper but it's far more complicated to
fix for good Mike Dr Global News
Toronto amazing or absurd next the
ambitious project to restore one of
Egypt's
[Music]
pyramids
there's a reason Egypt's pyramids draw
so many visitors they're amazing unlike
anything else in the world and they are
of course thousands of years old no one
expects them to look perfect but now one
of them near Cairo is getting an Extreme
Makeover and as Redmond Shannon explains
the plan is being both mocked and
applauded the three Pyramids of Giza
stand mostly as they were in 2500 BC the
main change this smoother outer layers
of stone Stripped Away over the
centuries but according to the head of
Egypt's Supreme Council of Antiquities
the smaller pyramid of menare May soon
more closely match its Glory years of
the fourth Dynasty in Giza only Mena
features these Granite casing blocks
they used to reach halfway up the 65 M
structure Mustafa waziri says those that
have fallen off are being gathered or
excavated cataloged and will eventually
be reset on the pyramid to look
something like this weri calls it the
project of the century but not everyone
is so excited one Cairo based
egyptologist called the plan
unbelievable and Akin to tiling the
pyramid she asked other academics to
stand against the project like Professor
Aiden Dodson it's the Devil's in the
detail the concept of putting some of
the putting the stone which has fallen
off back fine my concern would be is if
they want to take it further than that
and start putting new material in place
Dodson says the type of bonding cement
used is important along with whether
they will also want to restore this
smooth Limestone casing on the top half
something that would have to involve new
Stones so why is this happening now well
we can only speculate are people that
deciding not to go on holiday to the
Middle East so I think the idea is
partly just to get to grab people's
imaginations wasi says his project will
take three years in pyramid terms that
is but the blink of an eye Redman Chann
and Global News
London and that is global national for
this Tuesday I'm Donna freezen tonight's
your Canada something a little younger
the leaf at a Cino Park in Winnipeg it
has four distinct biomes it houses all
kinds of plants just beautiful we'd love
to see your Canada please email it to
viewers at global.com and hope to see
you here again tomorrow
[Music]
bye-bye